[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages as they come in time to
see what's making the headlines with the
columnist carol malone and the editor of
the career david clegg welcome to you
with us right through until midnight so
let's check out the front pages the
daily telegraph reports that boris
johnson is expected next week to break a
manifesto pledge and announce a rise in
national insurance to pay for the
biggest overhaul in social care funding
in a generation
the metro leading with britain's
shortage of workers saying it has
widened from hgv drivers and hospitality
staff to nurses and carers with 1.66
million advertised jobs now unfilled
british gas owner centrica warning of
soaring prices caused by a global supply
crunch that could raise household bills
that makes the front of the financial
times
dog nappers could be jailed for seven
years in a major crackdown as thefts of
pets almost triple in lockdown that is
the lead story for the daily mail the
guardian goes with a former cabinet
secretary warning that britain and its
allies have no coherent plan to deal
with a huge refugee crisis expected to
follow the taliban's takeover of
afghanistan
the sun reports that ministers are
urging scientists to make a decision on
vaccinating teenagers and booster jabs
for the over 50s
and the career goes with the scottish
tory msp apologizing to nicola sturgeon
after suggesting the first minister
nicolas sturgeon was anti-english
talk more about that in a bit uh david
well tonight as you can see joined by
carolyn david and certainly the lead
story carol for the daily telegraph has
been bubbling for some time
how to pay for social care and whether
you raid the coffers of uh
of national insurance what does the
paper say
i know it's saying that that boris is
expected to make an announcement next
week i mean this is i think this is one
taxes it's a national insurance rate
saying it could be between one and one
point two five percent and it's going to
call that's i mean
this is one tax that i don't think
anyone can just define and complain
about um you know this this boost for
social care is long overdue it's been
it's been the shame of many
previous governments and this one that
we have seen here the elderly um
just just being kind of the last on
every list when money is being handed
out so i think this is going to be a
very well i think this is going to be
welcome for social care and i don't
think people complain the thing that it
is that it does break the tories
manifesto pledge of 290 where they
promised not to raise taxes but i don't
see how else we're going to pay for
social care there's a massive massive
gap there people are being neglected you
the elderly don't say people you know
from from one day to the next and it's
and we know a lot of them aren't feeding
themselves they're not able to clean
themselves look after themselves so this
is this is just this is a tax that i'm
very happy to pay
interesting isn't it because we've got
the health service also wanting
something like 10 billion now or facing
a real shortfall um there's a there's a
lot of demand on the treasury if we can
put it that way david uh will people
feel the same way as carol that actually
social care paying for affect your own
future and that of your parents is the
right way to go
so i think i agreed with carol to an
extent and that is definitely true that
social care has been a disgrace for far
too long it is an issue that success of
governments have failed to tackle it is
one that uh must be tackled with urgency
you're also right that there's a vast
array of issues that are going to
require serious uh
public spending there's going to be
major financial implications on the nhs
indeed but also all the
covert and pandemic spending that we're
expecting in the years to come
where i think carol is wrong is that
national insurance is not the right tax
with which to address this uh it is that
across the board national insurance rise
which i think will affect about 25
million people will hit the hardest
young people and low earners
and and and that those are groups that
are struggling and have been struggling
and and require support it is not as
progressive as it could be even even
even an income tax rise even trying to
raise it through income tax on high
earners would would be a much better way
to do it i think i think if we do this
there's a there's a few elements of it
that cause problems it it just is uh
on
pensioners who are earning extra income
won't pay on that because you stop
paying national insurance after 66
it won't affect people who make money
generally wealthy people who make money
from renting out second homes for
example it won't be income from pensions
or from owning a business so this is
very much a tax where the the weight
will fall on young people and low
earners and i do not think that that is
necessarily the right approach for this
i definitely think it's right that
social care needs to be addressed it
needs a massive injection of money the
government needs somewhere to find that
from somewhere
boris johnson is of course breaking a
manifesto pledge but that's not a great
surprise to anyone i think
i think the way they're doing it is
wrong though
well the major political challenge for
the government will be hold on a minute
karen just read a bit about the major
political challenge for the government
will be winning approval for its
national insurance rise both with the
public and with tory mps who are
ideologically opposed to tax rises and
the figures they give are around 32
million people aged over 16 are in
employment in the uk and more than 25
million of them pay national insurance
according to the an estimate from the
resolution foundation so the point
you're making um carol is if it's spread
between 25 million and we are all
benefiting from it then that is the best
way to do it right or not
completely yes and and i think you know
it has been shameful over the past few
years that the elderly has you know have
built up
they own their own home and sometimes
they're having to sell their home from
underneath them to to get the social
care that they need and boris is talking
with this particular uh tax credit
talking about putting a cap on
social care can be paid for the cap is
going to be between they think between
60 and 80 000 so people will have to pay
care after that amount so you know i
think you know
the idea of of the elderly you know
having saved all their lives they have a
home and having to sell it um i i find
you know i think it's you know at that
time of your life you don't want to sell
yet that you've been in for however many
years and so i mean this will hopefully
stop that
care costs david are high already we
know let's go to the metro which talks
about the problem now of staffing we've
seen it with hgvs we know that their
wages have been rising which to many
people is a good news story that's one
of the reasons people wanted brexit to
see domestic workers have their wages go
up but if that happens in the care
industry it becomes harder to pay for
this doesn't it
yeah i think we're seeing the law of
unintended consequences here we've seen
the empty shells in the supermarket
we've seen the
fuel shortages
uh we've even seen a shortage of beer
and some of the pubs around near me
which i was particularly concerned about
so there's there's clearly big damage
here and now we're seeing the care
crisis and i think there is
um a serious issue here i think you know
there's there's a general acceptance
that wages in the care sector have have
been low they sh they should be higher
but equally we need that care it has a
massive knock-on effect on the nhs if if
there is if they're holding up
discharges from hospitals for example uh
and i think just there's a real
it's almost like so many uh issues
coming together we have brexit we have
the issues that are being called caused
i think largely by uh covered on the
pandemic as it's been known with lots of
people not able to work because they're
self-isolating uh or have a positive
test so there is there is there is real
chaos here and it's starting to filter
through into different sectors uh and i
think we need some kind of overall
strategy a government response to that
because i think really we haven't seen
much joined up thinking and how they're
going to tackle this major workforce
shortage that we're seeing at 1.66
million uh jobs that can't be filled at
the minute uh according to the metro
front page that's that's an incredible
amount of of jobs needing filled in a in
a country which has actually ironically
something
a similar number of people unemployed so
there's there's there's big issues here
and i think we need some kind of um
strategy for tackling them yes that's
confusing
i was just going to say i just wanted to
talk about is that i mean i get the
russia shortage in the care i mean this
this hgv shortage this is something
that's been a long time coming this is
supplements this is something that the
government knew about that the road
haulage association knew about and it's
not because of brexit to do with hgv
drivers it's to do with poor pay it's to
do with supermarkets who are driving
down the value
with people it was that was the testing
that usually there are there are it's 40
000 hdv tests in a year last year there
were 15 000 so that's got nothing to do
with brexit that's got to do with bad
organization and it's and you can't be
blaming brexit for the fact that we have
a shortage of hgv drivers that's that's
in part down to the supermarket it's in
part down to poor pay and it's in part
down to the fact that the tests haven't
been done this year yeah you do you do
blame brexit for some of it though don't
you we know in the care sector there was
a very high proportion of
people in this foreign
working in care homes if the pay was
better you know we filled the care homes
with eastern europeans and people from
europe because they were prepared to
take low pay and that drove down the pay
rates the same with the european leader
they were prepared to take less than the
going rate so they could send money home
and that's what's happening we don't pay
these people enough it's a really tough
job and we pay we don't pay good money
for it a lot of cans are privately run
so the profits aren't going to the
people who work there they're going to
the people who own the care homes uh
well the uh metro store is 4.66 million
i'm just going to quote some figures
i just very quickly uh said it's an a
leap of 193 000 in just one week
and the figures come from the
recruitment and employment confederation
suggesting that they now no longer have
enough staff to take in hospital
patients ready to be discharged or there
are those referred for help by councils
and certainly weeded a piece on the isle
of wight and their care staffing crisis
this week too so this is a real problem
because if you don't get the care
you know what happens to people um david
just quickly
yeah i mean i think i don't disagree
with anything carol said there
necessarily about this character
issue it is the fact that we've been
paying people to less too little and we
need and they need better wages but the
point is the way we've gone about this
now has caused this pinch point where we
just don't have people to do work and it
is the most essential work we need these
jobs filled we need these people looked
after we need this care being provided
uh and i think the almost
the chaotic way we've got ourselves into
this situation means we're in a point of
real crisis i think
lots more still to come we'll get on to
the dog napping story you've not even
picked out but we're going to do our but
surely we're going to do our
anyway also this one millions to get
booster jabs this is the daily express
reporting that all over 50s are in line
for a top-up vaccine that and then i
hope in a moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now columnist carol
malone and the editor of the courier
david clegg welcome back to both of you
seven years jail for dog nappers david
that's steep in the mail
it's very steep it's a story that's in
the front of the mail it's also in the
telegraph it's a story close to my heart
because i'm getting a new puppy on
sunday i've been in the i've been i've
been trying to buy a puppy recently and
i cannot i think part of this is the
prices have gone up massively dur during
the covet lockdown it's very expensive
dogs which is obviously made them more
attractive to steal but the plan here is
to not just talk about the value of the
dog but actually reflect the fact about
the cruelty and the suffering that the
animal might suffer uh so seven years is
a is a big big penalty and i think i
think it's quite an interesting move for
the government to be coming out and i'm
promoting this just now i suspect they
think it'll be a vote winner from animal
lovers
and they've been given quite a quite a
push in the papers tomorrow yeah just
quickly as well carol i mean it's puppy
farms but it's also people breeding dogs
who don't really know what they're doing
we normally we see your dog bowls in the
dog bed and normally normally the dog by
this time should be fair
you know it destroys families with them
when their pet gets turned in this way
now this new law was going to recognize
the fact that dogs are sentient beings
that they think and they feel and that
they will be distressed and it's about
time that people realize that it's not
just about the value of them anymore
these these animals are part of a family
and they can destroy it from it it fills
me with horror to think that someone
might pinch my dog i mean i would i'd be
thinking every hour of every day what
he's going through so yes these people
should be punished i just hope the
courts go ahead with this when this is
made into a law i hope that the courts
don't bot landed because currently
they're the sentences they give for
animal cruelty and it's they're visible
so i hope it changes
yes um to to the idea of booster jabs
david is he frozen another you're back
again um daily express uh millions to
get booster jabs
it says all over 50s are in line for a
top-up covered vaccine well if we look
at the sun as well
more jabbing less jabber it's time to
roll out boosters for over 50s and
decide on kids i think everyone just
wants a decision decision now don't they
yes there has been some confusing
rhetoric about this and i've been
finding it quite difficult to follow
exactly where we are and exactly what's
going on with different recommendations
and of course the the different
governments across the uk but i think
there seems to be certainly a sense from
the uk government and boris johnson that
they want as many vaccines as possible
they want the booster job for the over
50s and also they want the scientists to
get together and give the approval uh
for for various other criteria as well
so that they they really can't try and
keep on top of this because we have seen
the numbers creeping up particularly in
scotland it feels at the minute like you
can't really move in scotland about a
covered outbreak somewhere so i think it
is quite clear that um they need to be
taking uh more action on this and the
action that they want to take is to deal
with vaccines they do not want to be
having to get into a situation where
they're uh going back into some kind of
covert restrictions or or for or for
more
restrictions on our day-to-day life
again that was after enjoying freedom
for the last few months so i think i
think this is something that we want to
see more over the days to come
yes
it focuses the mind doesn't it very
quickly but
i just don't think david's right that in
this country last week the only
announcement that was made that was the
500 000
people who who are compromised with our
immune system were going to get it's
only this week after a huge protest that
actually they're now saying that people
over 50 may get it because i mean we
have to do what's the point of the
vaccine
if we know immunity wanes we've run out
of time carol and david thank you very
much indeed great to see you